here's my shape I'd love you to draw it
include those measurements now that I've
fixed them
what's the name of this shape it's their
name of this check it's a I can hear it
triangular prism okay all of the shapes
were going to look at in the next little
bit our prisms we named the prism after
it's because that's the important
feature of that a prism remember all the
cross-sections here are going to be
trained wood you can cut in other ways
you just won't get the same
cross-sections and that time we don't
worry about those okay it's a triangular
prism what I'm gonna do is I want to
think about the net of this shape I
don't have to think about all in one
piece right that's okay
I you need to make sure I don't miss any
of the signs so we did diagram it and
make it nice and decent the center size
if you have another color there that'll
be useful how many faces on it in
Academy I count one this big one right
in the front to the one on the bottom
three the back and then four and five
other ends do you agree with me you see
five as well okay now just a bit of tip
we said was a triangular prism right
triangular prism the triangles going to
give you three and then because it's a
prism there's going to be two ends three
plus two okay you can cut it manually
every time if you like but just suppose
you have got a triangular prism but a
hexagonal prism hexagonal prism without
drawing it could you count how many
faces you get again the hexagons will
give you six faces and then there's a
front and a back so you'd have eight in
total does that make sense just a bit of
a shortcut way okay we'll go five faces
we want to make sure we capture each of
them right I'm going to label them
someone call this one the front here you
got the bottom you've got the back
and then rather than call this like
another name because this is some point
to the shape I'm going to call this guy
the cross-section because after all it
is a triangular prism like so the
triangle is the cross-section
now there are five phases but I've only
labeled four of them why is that because
yet Daniel all the way through fantastic
okay if the cross-section is there on
the this side it's going to be there on
the back as well you don't need to do it
again just double whatever that happens
to be so far so good
okay so let's just do this one at a time
the cross-sections on the front it's a
triangle so the area of the
cross-section is okay think area of a
triangle
what's our formula yet yeah half base
times height half base times time okay
you can write the formula if you like
but these domes are pretty simple
they're all just sitting there so I'm
going to go 1/2 7 times 24 yeah
I'm glad you asked that by the way
before I hits that question I left
something off this diagram a right angle
we need that the question was since
there's two of them do I have to do the
half can I just go straight to 7 times
24 hmm
my short answer for that is yes you can
if all that matters to you is the number
you get at the end because 2 times 1/2
times 7 times 24 is the same as 7 times
24 right but it's not just the number at
the end that matters to me and it
shouldn't be just the number the menace
to you I need to see how you got there
right and that's 1/2 times 7 times 24
and there's two of them eventually the
two and a half cancel but I want to see
you thinking I want to see you
communicating I know there are two sides
and I know what each area is does that
make sense
so way I'm gonna do it because I'm gonna
say 1/2 times 7 times 24 1/2 times 24 is
12 so 7 times 12 is 87 times tables sick
that's 84 and my units are square Center
well I started with the cross section
because I got all those measurements
then I also have all the measurements on
the bottom so I'm gonna say area look
carefully at your diagram what are the
measurements that are relevant 7 in the
40 and what kind of shape is it
it's just a rectangle so it's just
length times breath that's it
so 7 times 47 touch 4,200 very good ok
done the cross-section done the area the
bottom the area on the back I also have
all the measurements there it's not
quite as obvious the area on the back
that's this rectangle that's standing up
what's the height of that rectangle it's
24 you can see it there what about the
width across the bottom it's still 40
yeah
so therefore the area of the back
is going to be the 24 you said up here
and the 40 you said over here
24 times 4960 throat fire good job guys
okay I've just got one of the faces left
the front can anyone tell why I left it
to last yeah I mean yeah I'm missing a
measurement on tight it's a rectangle I
know how wide it is but I do not know
what this measurement here is right but
I can work it out how am I gonna do it
soon I've got this remember I said this
right angle triangle is going to be
important to me so I've got to work this
out seven squared plus 24 squared I
happen to know is 625 does anyone know
what 625 is the square of a 5qj
so you of course I don't expect you to
work that in your head you've got
calculator there but that'll be 25
centimeters okay once you work that out
I highly encourage you to put that onto
a diagram I've run out of space over
here but you should keep going down the
page the area of the front therefore is
going to be 25 times 40 and that's
exactly about fantastic okay got all my
pieces I'm ready to bring it all
together that's possible area okay
remember that cross-section how many of
those do I have again two of it
intestine sewer the cross-section Plus
every other number I worked out to 8960
thousand yeah hmm I'm in expect that in
your head do you want to punch that in
to calculate it and tell me what number
you think say to get a bit lucky
thousand two thousand four hundred and
eight eight thank you can I get some
agreement on that someone else about
that yep good job